FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello
and welcome.
We're very pleased to have been
Vincent Versace with us
today here at Google.
He's been a longtime friend of
ours, and he'll be talking
about photography.
That's that we're here for.
The title of his presentation is
the Lens is the Brush, the
Camera is the Canvas, and the
File is the Sheet Music, and
the Print is the Symphony.
So all these things come
together to create a beautiful
final image.
Vincent has up a long line and
list of accolades, and I can't
possibly go through
all of them.
I'll just pinpoint a few.
And Vincent, if I
miss anything,
you can jump in there.
VINCENT VERSACE: That's OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
He's been recognized as a
pioneer in the art and science
of digital photography.
He has been a recipient of the
Computerworld Smithsonian
Award in Media Arts and
Entertainment as well as a
permanent collection in the
Smithsonian Institute's Museum
of American History Vincent has
been highlighted in all
the major magazines
for photography--
many, many photography
magazines--
and he's also really well-known
for some of his
bestselling books.
He has one called "From Oz To
Kansas, Almost Every Black And
White Technique Known To
Mankind" and "Welcome to Oz
2.0, The Cinematic Approach
to Digital Photography in
Photoshop," and he has
several others.
Vincent has a brilliant mind.
If you ever have a chance to
talk and listen to him, you're
in for a real treat,
as you are today.
So Vincent, thanks very
much, and welcome.
VINCENT VERSACE: Thank
to you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
VINCENT VERSACE: I love coming
to a place where no matter
where I am, I feel
like the absolute
dumbest kid in the room.
This place is--
the way in which every little
detail is thought of, it's
gotten to the point where,
of course you did.
It's great.
You live in heaven here and
make the best orange
shortbread cookies
I have ever had.
So where's the HR person?
Because you could just
pay me in cookies.
I'm OK.
I'm easy that way.
So what is it that you would
like to get from me?
What is your expectation of this
interaction, besides a
fancy-ass title?
Life story.
How I get from here to here
to there to this.
How I get this to look like this
while translating this
from this to this, and why that
affects this to this to
that, that comes over here.
How'd I do?
AUDIENCE: We're done.
VINCENT VERSACE: Thank
you very much.
Right place, right time.
How I became a beta tester was
back in the day, there was a
booth about this big in the
photography area of Nikon.
And there was nobody that was a
professional that wanted to
do digital photography, because
there was no way
digital photography was ever
going to take over film.
And this poor guy that was there
in this booth was one
step out the door, because
nobody's going to buy an
electronic camera!
And the big photographers that
were willing to do it wanted
hundreds of thousands of
dollars, because any pictures
that they took would be useless
to them forever.
And me, right out of
college, went, I'll
do it for the camera.
And that's really right
place, right time.
And be willing to be paid in
orange shortbread cookies.
That's really what
it comes down to.
So what I want to talk about how
it all interplays, because
it all interplays.
Everything dovetails into
everything else.
I'm going to start with passion
in the photograph.
The quickest way to take better
photographs is to stop
taking photographs.
Let the photograph take you.
Be taken by your pictures.
It is not about smile
now, damn it!
It is about that moment
where you go [GASPS].
And as you're being grabbed, the
journey is not this way.
The journey is this way.
And as you're being ripped
through that lens, watching
cool things happen, the finger
should be shooting.
I shoot so much that according
to my doctor, I have a stress
fracture on this finger
and these fingers.
I couldn't figure out why my
hand was killing me, and it's
like, well, how much did
you shoot when you
were in Burma last?
And I'm looking at it.
I have 136,000 frames.
His response was, perhaps
shoot less.
My response was, rebuild me.
So the response, it has to
be absolutely automatic.
Things travel at the
speed of life.
And rather than noodling the
photograph and concerning
yourself about did I get
it right, forget that.
What you need to get
is you need to let
the moment take you.
You need to let the moment that
moved you to the point
where you are witnessing the
most amazing thing be the
impulse to fire.
Things happen at the speed of
life, and a camera captures
things in fractions
of a second.
We see things in time
and motion.
A camera photographs things
in fractions of a second.
When adding up how much time I
have spent in Burma or India
or wherever--
I just did this with Burma--
when I was done, I was there
for two weeks, and if you total
up all the fractions of
seconds that I shot, I shot
two and a half minutes.
But I was there for two weeks.
I have stress fracture
on my shooting hand.
Why?
It's a numbers game.
Things happen at the
speed of life.
You set your camera up so that
it can do all of the things
that you don't want to worry
about, exposure,
focus, those things.
If you think about a D4--
I shoot Nikon, so I'm going to
speak in a Nikon metaphor--
if you think about a D4, D800,
those cameras, those are the
ultimate idiot-proof, or as we
like to refer to the computer
business, an ID10T camera,
total point and shoot.
Why?
Because I am busy concerning
myself about what is happening
in front of my camera.
I do not want to worry about
what my camera is doing.
To your question, how do you
make technology better?
You make it so that I can set it
up, and it does the things
I need it to do based on my
style, that there is some form
of understanding of what it
is that I'm shooting.
One of the advantages of my
system is the way in which its
meter works, which is
why I choose it.
It's a three-dimensional light
meter that's an RGB meter with
6.5 million pixel RGB meter
that meters in three
dimensions, and computes skin
tones, and backgrounds, and
things differently, so it
exposes differently.
Why?
I don't want to be paying
attention to all of that.
I need to be paying
attention to what?
The moment as it unfolds
in front of me.
The architect Mies van der Rohe
said, "An interesting
plainness is the most difficult
thing to achieve."
You want to have "blow
you away" pictures?
Photograph interesting
plainnesses, things that
others walk by so that you
create an image that stops the
viewer the same way
you were stopped.
The conversation in a
photograph is this.
Ansel Adams was asked, how
many people are in your
photographs?
And he said, well, me.
No.
The only thing I disagree with
him on all of his quotes is
the one person that doesn't
belong in your
photograph is you.
And here's the reason why,
in my philosophy of it.
Things happen in the
space between.
Photograph doesn't happen
over here, and it
doesn't happen over here.
It happens in this space,
the space between.
In karate, the reason why you
throw a punch and pull out
fast, versus planting it, is
that if you plant it, 90% of
the force of the impact
is left in the
hand if it's there.
If it comes in and pulls out,
90% of the impact is here.
Where do you want the impact
of your photograph to be?
In the photograph.
You want to create an image so
that it's as if the person who
is looking at it was standing
in the same place that you
were when the photograph
took you.
So if you can get to that
point, that's a
great place to be.
Well, how do you get to
that point, would be
a question to ask.
Do we agree on that?
Mr. Stuff, I'm about
to tell you.
How you get to that point is you
understand the middle part
of photography forwards,
backwards, upside down,
sideways, in any other
dimension, since we can talk
string theory here, and
you'll understand
what I'm talking about.
And then at point of capture,
promptly forget it.
There's a concept in Japanese
thought, in Zen Japanese
thought, called shibumi, which
is the ability to have
thoughtful, thoughtless thought,
to do the right thing
at the right time, in the
moment, without consciously
thinking about doing it.
You simply be it.
You simply do it.
How you get there is
through practice.
There's a misnomer that practice
makes perfect.
Practice does not
make perfect.
Perfect practice
makes perfect.
You have to practice
at practicing.
One of the great sorrows I have
as a teacher is I will go
to exotic places with people,
and I will do what I always
do, which is what would
you like this
conversation to be about?
And somebody will say to me,
well, I came here to learn how
to use my camera better.
How much money, time, and
effort did you spend for
buttonology lessons?
When you walk into the hairball
of photography, you
need to know that camera as
well as you know yourself.
Sun Tzu, "The Art Of War."
It's a great book on war.
It's a great book on life.
It's a great book on art.
You know your camera as well as
you know yourself, you will
know the outcome of
every photograph.
Know your camera half as well as
you know yourself, you get
half the shots, you lose
half the shots.
Don't know your camera means
you don't know yourself.
You were truly lost.
So where do you practice?
You practice here, where
it doesn't matter.
You carry a camera with
you everywhere you go.
You drive your cat crazy, your
significant other crazy, your
kids crazy, your
friends crazy.
Why?
Because you're crazy.
You decided to do photography,
right?
I mean, there are many more
things that one could do that
would be less nuts-making
than photography.
I'll give you another
question to ask you.
When you look at somebody's
work, do you know if
it's good or bad?
When you look at a picture,
you can say,
that's good, it's bad.
I like it, I don't like it.
You can do that.
You can go through these
pictures up here, and you will
make judgments as to whether or
not they're good or bad to
your aesthetic, correct?
Why can't you do that
with your own work?
Why can't you look at your own
pictures and say, this is
good, this is bad?
Why is it all crap?
Furthermore, why did you
choose a hobby in which
everything you do, you say
to yourself is what?
It's crap.
Really?
There are enough people to
beat you up in the world.
You do not need to assist.
Your biggest critic sits in
the same chair you do.
I contend that, no,
it isn't crap.
What the problems are is
understanding stuff.
Technology.
It is this interesting thing
that we do with technology.
We blame ourselves for the
problems of the technology,
and we blame the technology for
problems that are ourselves.
For example, a camera
meters at 18% gray.
That means if I shoot a white
wall and a black wall, and I
let the meter do it, I'm
going to get what?
Two 18% gray walls.
So we go out in this highly
dynamic, highly lit
environment, we take
a picture, and
it comes out flat.
And we say to ourselves,
I suck.
No!
The camera meters at 18% gray.
What sucks is the camera
meters at 18% gray.
So you change the way you expose
because you understand
the middle.
Here's the way I look at it.
You're traveling a circle, but
you're going to do it in a
straight line.
Every decision you need to make
about your photograph has
to happen where?
Moment of capture.
The more you understand about
the middle, the more informed
your decision can be at the
beginning, because you're in
service of what?
The end.
The print.
What's the print
in service of?
Your voice.
Where does that happen?
At the beginning.
So it's this circle, but it's
like taking a circle and
making it a straight line.
Now one of the things that is
important to understand is the
first concept, the
lens as brush.
There is a reason when I pick up
a 64 pound camera bag that
I have in this--
I always feel like I'm a
Ringling Brothers clown, and
they're about to all
hop out with this.
There's a reason why I have a
200 millimeter, 70 to 200
F4.5, a 70 to 200
2.8, a 70 to 210
push-pull, a 24 to 120 nano.
My new rocket motor,
the 80 to 400.
That's a beautiful
piece of glass.
The 70 to 300.
I'm not done.
70 to 300, and the 28 to 300.
You get a feeling that
I nail 80 to 124?
I absolutely nail that
focal length.
Why?
Bokeh.
It's pronounced "bouquet." OK?
Not Boca.
Boca is a city in Florida,
also known as
God's waiting room.
I told that joke in Florida.
It did not go over.
Bokeh is a very unique
quality.
It's the quality of blur.
It's a harmonic that is caused
by all the things in the lens
that you don't want
a lens to do.
It's sort of like the Caesar
salad dressing of optics.
You laugh, Mr. Stuff.
But Mr. Camera Person
does not.
Life story wants to know,
how does this apply?
I'm a better cook than I am a
photographer, but I will never
be as great a cook as the
great cooks that I know.
So I spend a lot of time working
with how food works.
Caesar salad dressing.
It's made up of anchovies,
strong.
Raw garlic, strong.
Red wine vinegar, strong.
Coleman's hot mustard, strong.
Parmesan cheese, strong.
Olive oil, not so strong.
You put them all together,
what do you get?
A mild dressing.
Why?
Because each one of those things
cancels each other out
in a way in which creates a
harmonic that, if it's done
correctly, everything dovetails
into everything
else, and you have
a smooth flavor.
So all the things in a lens that
you don't want have to be
balanced in such
a way to create
something that you do want.
For example, how many Nikon
shooters do I have?
That just makes my day.
To you Canon shooters--
it's been years coming,
hasn't it?
This is the 72 to 210
D-series lens.
This is probably the lens
I built my career on.
This is the best portrait lens
you will ever, ever find.
If somebody is silly enough to
want to sell it to you, do
them a favor and relieve
them of it.
Why?
It has the best bokeh for
portraiture I have ever seen.
Linear objects, hair, stuff
like that, tack sharp.
Skin, perfectly smooth.
Background, beautiful,
beautiful, beautiful blend.
It has come down to why this
matters with something called
depth of field.
My favorite definition of depth
of field is Michael
Reitman's, which is a circle
of confusion is a bunch of
photographers sitting around a
table defining depth of field.
So let's talk about depth of
field and the illusion of
depth of field.
Let's agree on terms.
What are the parameters
of depth of field?
Aperture, do we agree?
Focal length.
Distance from a subject.
And if you want more crap in
focus, you stop the lens down.
No.
Focal length has nothing
to do with it.
Distance of the subject does,
aperture does, and something
called angle of view.
All lenses have the same
depth of field.
Why a wide-angle lens appears
to have a greater depth of
field than a telephoto lens
has to do with this.
The smaller an object is,
the more in focus
it appears to be.
The bigger an object is,
the less in focus
it appears to be.
How many people shot film?
OK.
For those of you who don't shoot
film, I agree, film is
what occurs in your teeth now
when you don't brush.
But back in the day, 35
millimeter film, if you looked
at a contact sheet, all
the pictures would
be in focus, right?
It wasn't until you put it in
the enlarger that all hell
broke loose.
Why?
Because as you blew the image
up, that's when you started to
see the blur.
The tighter the edge,
the more in focus.
The less coherent, the
bigger it is, the
less in focus it becomes.
That's the first thing.
Here's another proof.
An 80 millimeter lens on the
35 millimeter camera is a
telephoto lens, correct?
Slight telephoto,
but telephoto.
If we call 50 normal, 80 would
be in the realm of telephoto.
An 80 millimeter lens on 2.25
camera is the normal lens, and
an 80 millimeter lens on a
4 by 5 view camera is a
wide-angle lens.
What changed?
Angle of view.
So that's the first thing
to keep in mind.
I will get to why that
matters in a second.
The next one is the misnomer of
if you stop the lens down,
you get more things in focus.
That is not true according
to physics.
Unless you can introduce, my
favorite word in photography,
the Scheimpflug principle--
cool word, isn't it?
Swings and tilts.
Unless you can do this, if
you're dealing with a
fixed-lens system, which is
what this is, physics says
that the only thing that is in
focus is that which the lens
is physically focused upon and
anything that crosses the
plane of focus.
That means that anything from
the plane of focus is the
increasing area of acceptable
out of focus,
though it isn't in focus.
Now why we believe this to be
true has to do with film.
A lens, any one of these lenses
here, is capable of
resolving a minimum
of 200 line pair.
That's 200 black and white
lines per centimeter.
Film was between 150 and 170
line pair, which means that
the lens has greater resolution
than the film.
With me so far?
Silver paper was between
50 and 75 line pair.
So the lens has greater
resolution than the film, and
the film has significantly
greater resolution than the
photographic paper,
silver paper.
So anything above 75 line pair
will register as what?
75 line pair.
So you have the illusion of more
things in focus, but in
reality, what you have are more
things at 75 line pair.
Digital, the lens sees 200,
the sensor sees 200, and
high-end printers can print
upwards of 300 line pair,
which means that the output
device has greater resolution
than the file that you're
sending it.
So what are you going to see?
Blur ramp.
So this brings up a very
interesting question, which
goes back to yours, yours,
yours, and trust me when I
tell you, yours.
Trust me.
Which is, what's your photograph
more about, in
focus or in blur?
What do you worry about more,
in focus or in blur?
You worry about in
focus, right?
But only one thing in your
photograph's in focus.
So you're spinning your wheels
worrying about less than 1% of
the image when most
of your image is
about the ramp of blur.
Here's another one.
You want four objects in
a photograph in focus?
What do you know you need?
Four photographs.
Because you can't have four
objects in focus in a digital
camera because of
the resolutions.
The trick with the photograph
is that when you're all said
and done, it looks like you
didn't do anything, and the
person looking at your
photograph will believe that
they could go right
out and shoot it.
And at the same time, what
you've done is that when they
look at a flower, if you took
a picture of a flower, for
that much time they
see your flower.
Then they see the flower that
they're looking at.
How you accomplish this task
and where pretty is in a
photograph--
and if you want to pick one of
the great epiphany moments of
my career visually, to answer
how do you do this, was when I
realized that my photograph was
more about the blur than
it was about the focus.
All lenses focus.
That is what lenses do.
That's their job.
But it is how they handle from
in focus to blur, which is
where the pretty is.
Are you making the seed packet
photograph, or you're trying
to make a piece of art?
Are you putting something in the
Encyclopedia Britannica,
or the Encyclopedia Americana,
or Wikipedia, or you're trying
to make something that
moves somebody?
That's the question.
If what you're trying to do is
accurately document something,
then focus, stack the thing, put
it [? in Helicon ?] focus,
make one big in focus
photograph, and call it a day.
If what you're trying to do is
to move the viewer's eye
around the photograph and tell
the story you want to told,
because you want to move the
viewer in a certain way, then
we're in a different realm.
And the more you understand
the physics
of this, the math--
and what is a great thing for
me is that I give this
discussion quite a bit, and
the fact that everybody in
this room could probably correct
me on my math really
makes my day.
So you have to understand
how these work.
For example, does light travel
in a straight line?
Not according to Einstein.
According to Einstein,
light bends.
Light's both a wave and a
particle at the same time.
The reason why these lenses are
designed the way they are
is so that red, green,
and blue hit the
sensor at the same time.
Nothing about the journey of
light down this barrel is a
straight line.
It does move in a forward
direction, but it doesn't move
in a straight line.
So natural light has a whole
different set of things that
it does, attributes, that
strobe light doesn't.
It's both ambient and
directional at the same time.
You can light in a ball.
Hot light works the same way,
which is why I tend to use
those lights, that
type of lighting,
because it's prettier.
It's also the more difficult
and the simpler types of
lighting to do at
the same time.
It requires a greater
understanding of how light
works to be able to shoot
it, but it's everywhere.
What I look at when I look at
these is the bokeh of the
lens, how it handles blur.
Apertures that I shoot at, I
shoot wide open, I do portrait
at 5.6, and I do landscape at F8
or F11, depending on where
the critical aperture, which
is where the light's most
evenly distributed across
the lens system, is.
F22 does not give me
the sharpest image.
F22 gives me the greatest area
of acceptable out of focus.
So again, it's understanding
your glass.
There's a--
is it borrowlenses.com?
Rent some lenses.
See how they work.
Play with the blur.
You will find prettier
in the blur than
you will in the focus.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to show you a slide show
in which when you see this,
there will be no music if you
watch this on YouTube, but
you'll hear the music here.
We will agree this is
a weapon system.
Nothing says professional
photographer, high
anti-spontaneity than
a camera like this.
This is the ultimate point
and shoot camera.
I program the back for
the parameters that
I want it set for--
color space, way I want it to
white balance, how I want
picture control to handle
things, at what speed I'm
going to shoot.
I put this on aperture priority,
and I have a
focusing system that
[SNAPS], OK?
So it's not the little green
button which decides
everything for me.
I decide before I walk in what
it is that I think the
environment is going
to require from me.
I also shoot in the raw,
but not in the buff.
I'll be very clear about that.
That will get you arrested.
The reason why I shoot in the
raw is a raw file allows me to
rebake a cake.
The only thing that I can't
unto is ISO and bad
photography.
Other than that, I can
change everything.
So I come up with a set of
parameters that I think will
fit, and I want to offload as
much as I possibly can the
things that I don't want to
worry about, like exposure.
I want this camera calling the
ball whenever possible on
exposure, because it will
do it better than I
can, most of the time.
I want this camera
auto-focusing
because it will focus--
because of these, right?
Sharper than I can, and
quicker than I can.
Because what I want to be
doing is I want to be
practicing on reacting
to the moment.
So that's why I picked this
camera system, because the
camera system allows me to set
it up, and it's kind of my
little green button.
So did I connect that for you?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
VINCENT VERSACE: OK.
So that I practice.
And then the other thing that
is important is I can tell
what's going on with my camera
by the sound of the shutter.
That's important.
Like if I'm in a really dark
room, and I'm hearing click,
click, click, that's
ISO, way too high.
Or if you're outside on a bright
day, and you're just
hearing that camera shoot off
at an 1/8,000 of the second,
that tells you you haven't
done something correctly.
So it's understanding the
majority of what the menus do
on the back and how to set
it up is important.
Again, it's understanding the
system so completely that when
you set it up, you don't have
to worry about it, that you
can hear by sound what is going
on, that by the way in
which the camera is shooting
tells you that something is or
is not correct on it.
I always do something called
VSE, Visual Search of
Extremities.
When the camera is in the camera
bag, and I pull it out,
the first thing I do is turn
it on just make sure
everything is set right.
Because there are gremlins that
live in camera bags, and
they turn the camera on, they
push the buttons, and they
turn it off.
And all of a sudden,
you don't know.
Or somebody decides they want
to look at your camera.
They play with all
your buttons.
I was out shooting in Burma,
and somebody played with my
camera, and put it into JPEG--
I don't know what's
below garbage.
And I'm shooting this picture,
and it's like bing, bing,
bing, bing, bam!
And it's like, something's
not right.
And I shot this entire
sequence of
JPEG basic in SRGB.
And it was just, like, really?
A little closer, just
a little closer.
This gets into the other
part of it, which
is camera as canvas.
I have two D800s,
a D600 and a D4.
One D800 is converted for
infrared, and then I have the
D600, and the D4,
and the D800.
Why would I possibly want to
have that many different types
of resolution in a camera?
I don't want to shoot a portrait
at 36 megapixels.
That's like retouching
an orange.
That's hours of work.
I want a, nice, smooth
skin tone.
I want to be able to shoot
at very low light
when I shoot a portrait.
Why?
Because lower light has
a prettier quality.
I want to shoot a landscape, so
what am I going to shoot?
I'm whipping out that D800,
thank you very much.
I have no idea what is going to
face me when I go to shoot.
What camera do I pick?
D600.
Why?
4,000 ISO, no noise, 24
megapixels, no problem.
Each camera is a different
canvas that
does a different thing.
It's a different tool.
And each one of these lenses
combined with that creates a
different look.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to show you a bunch of
images in which what I would
like you to see here, first,
is my commitment to the moment,
which is the things
that move me, and you're going
to see some of the infrared
stuff as well.
And we will get into that.
And you're going to see a
journey of my life, part of
which is all the different
places I go.
Because, you see, my photographs
really are the
snapshots of the vacation
that is my life.
I'm amazed that I get
paid to do this.
I'm happy I get paid to do this,
but there's a different
story than the photograph tells,
that the photograph--
how do I put this?
The photograph tells one story,
but there's a different
story behind each photograph.
I'm going to tell you one story
about one photograph
after I show you this.
So let's see if this works.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VINCENT VERSACE: Proof that
children are indeed born in
cabbage patches.
So what you should see is that
there's a lot of use of blur
in that photograph and a
lot of use of focus.
And the objects that I want
you to see are in focus.
There's some other things that
I do, which is I don't really
pay too much attention to
composition theory,
particularly 17th century
painting composition theory.
Rule of thirds, Grecian mean,
the center of the frame is for
God, not you, or the center of
the frame is the best place to
put the object.
You decide.
What I pay attention to is the
biomechanics of vision.
What is looking at
the picture?
17th century composition theory
or a set of eyeballs?
Eyeballs.
So what should I pay
attention to?
Eyeballs.
Here's how the eye works.
It goes to a pattern that it
recognizes first in the area
of light, then to dark.
I want you to watch
a trend here.
It then goes from high contrast
to low contrast.
What is contrast?
Bueller?
The ratio between
light and dark.
It goes from high sharpness
to low sharpness.
What is sharpness, or
specifically, unsharpness?
And if we want to get really
technical, the
Craik-O'Brien-Cornsweet
edge illusion.
What is that?
What is unsharpness
in a computer?
The introduction of contrast
to the edges of things.
The human eye is a
contrast beast.
It works on varying degrees
of contrast.
It then goes from in focus to
blur, which is different than
high to low sharpness.
High saturation of color to low
saturation of color, which
is another form of contrast.
Warm colors move forward
in the picture.
Cool colors recede
in a picture.
So my job is to control your eye
and where it goes, because
the most important thing to keep
in mind is that the human
eye doesn't want to
look at anything.
It's always in a seek mode.
Women understand this concept
better than men.
You're out on a date, a pretty
woman walks in, what
does the guy do?
Always in the seek mode.
So my job is to create a
situation where you can't stop
looking at the photograph.
It's my picture, right?
I decide where the viewers eye
goes based on being true to
the emotional moment
that took me.
So how do I do that?
Well, I use the middle part,
software, to control how
things go about.
Contrast, sharpness, light,
dark, detail enhancement,
detail degradation, blur.
All of these things are things
that I try to do.
Now, what I have found is
in-camera blur is better than
digital blur, so what I try to
do is create images that will
give me the varying levels of
blur that I want and the
varying levels of sharpness that
I want, that there's a
point where I start
looking at the
picture as image structure.
Now, there are two schools
of thought.
There's a school of thought,
Ansel Adams school of thought,
which says that without
previsualization, the zone
system is just a five finger
exercise, so you need to
previsualize the photograph.
And then there is Paul
Caponigro's school of thought,
which is if you believe in
previsualization, you deserve
what you get.
Both are correct.
You don't want to walk into a
situation previsualizing what
picture you're going to take,
because all you're ever going
to do is be disappointed.
Because the picture that you're
dreaming to see will
never occur.
What I previsualize when
I walk in to shoot, I
previsualize being amazed.
The moment I fire the shutter,
at that moment, I start
previsualizing the
finished picture.
When I was a kid growing up--
see, I turned that, right?
There was a poster that my
father had of a "Saturday
Evening Post" cover called
"The Connoisseur." It's a
picture of a Jackson Pollock
scribble, and there's this guy
standing like this, holding
a bowler hat and a pair of
gloves, looking at this Jackson
Pollack scribble.
Every time I take a picture, the
ones that really grab me,
in that moment in my head, I put
the picture in that frame
with that guy looking at it.
And so when I'm working on the
image in post-processing
software, for me what it is is
removing everything that is
not that picture, what
Michelangelo said about sculpting.
He viewed the rock as a living
stone, and he removed
everything that was not the
sculpture, and he freed the
sculpture from the rock.
The file is the living file,
and what I do is I free my
vision of the image
from that file.
And the thing you have to keep
in mind when you're working on
an image is that magenta, kind
of puke yellow, low contrast
file you're looking at that's
a raw file, that's the
cleanest the data
will ever be.
Everything that you do to that
file from that moment forward,
you're clipping data, and the
minute you clip data, you
introduce artifact.
Correct?
We all know that.
Now, artifacting is both
cumulative and may be
multiplicative.
And the goal is to--
and this always sounds like
a Disney song to me--
minimize the cumulative and
negate the multiplicative.
Can you see that being
a Disney song?
So the trick is in how you
post-process the image so that
you negate the multiplication
aspects of artifacting, and
you just deal with cumulative,
and you work at minimizing it.
Which is why I use the tools I
use, and which is why I build
things in layers.
Instead of putting it all on one
layer, I have many layers.
It's not because I like to
give myself busywork.
It's because I like to make it
so that I can blow the picture
up 16 feet if I want
to, because I
minimize the artifact.
The key elements of
a photograph--
light, gesture, color.
That's Maisel.
And if you're not familiar with
Jay Maisel, you should
look him up.
I think he's probably the
greatest breathing
photographer we have.
Mine, because I can't leave
well enough alone--
light, gesture, color,
and time.
Specifically, timeless.
If you can create a photograph
where you have no idea when it
was shot, those are truly the
most successful photographs.
Here's a couple of things
that I've learned.
Timeless in a city happens
four stories and above.
Go to San Francisco.
Next time you're in San
Francisco, look at where the
banners end for the Giants
or the next exhibition at
whatever gallery.
Look at where all
the neon ends.
It ends at the bottom of the
third floor, at the beginning
of the fourth floor.
If you shoot from the fourth
floor up, what you see is the
age of the city when those
buildings were shot.
There's another thing.
There's a photographer
named [? Duino ?].
I used to look at his work,
and he was one of those
photographers for me which
whenever I looked at his
pictures, it was,
I'm not worthy.
I should go find a job where I
say "would you like fries with
that?" I mean, just not worthy
to take a picture.
His work was so amazing.
His backgrounds were
so incredible.
So I did something that guys
don't normally do.
Basically, I read the book.
Instead of looked at the book,
I read the instructions.
And he had one quote that just
stuck with me. "I find the
stage, and the
players come." Brilliant!
What the man would do is he
would go find the background,
set the camera up, get it all
set, sit down, have a cup of
coffee, and wait for stuff
to walk into his picture.
That's brilliant!
That's absolutely the best
way to shoot, because the
background is as important
as the foreground.
And if your background is
interesting, and then you have
an in-focus subject, the
picture's even more compelling
and interesting.
So I would invite you to
consider, in your quest for
how do you make them better,
find the stage, and the
players will come.
Pay attention to the background
as much as you pay
attention to the foreground.
What's more important
in a photograph, the
light or the subject?
What do you think?
Subject?
OK.
Do you know what the word
"photography" means?
Photo-graphy, "to write with
light." what would you rather
look at, the Taj Mahal poorly
lit or a line of clothing
beautifully lit?
Treat light as if it
was a solid object.
It's as important to the
photograph, if not more
important to the photograph,
sometimes
than the subject itself.
If the light is beautiful,
all sorts of
wonderful things happen.
Now, here's one for you.
What's the fastest thing
in the universe?
Unless you're a Trekkie, then
it's tachyons, right?
Doesn't it amaze you that dark
always seems to be there
before light?
Doesn't that trip you out?
Now, yes, light is the fastest
thing that we know of in the
universe, but dark in a
photograph is as important to
the photograph as light.
And the way in which
I remember that--
Terry Pratchett came up
with that quote--
is that dark is always
there before it.
I need to have dark in my
photograph to have drama, to
have contrast, to control the
ideas of the picture.
I need to have in-focus,
I need to have blur.
These are the elements
that I work with.
That's why these lenses
are my brushes.
These cameras, because of the
different resolutions, become
my canvas that I paint on,
because I pick the camera that
I'm going to use based on what
is the needs of what it is
that I'm going to do.
Now, I'm going to show you some
pictures of flowers in
which almost all of them are
multiple photographs, and what
I want you to pay
attention to--
this concept is image
harvesting.
You've heard of high dynamic
range, right?
Or how to make your picture look
like a Harry Potter set?
This is EXDR, Extending the
Dynamic Range of everything.
You can extend the dynamic
range of time.
range of focus.
You can extend the dynamic
range of blur.
range sharpness.
You can extend the dynamic range
of color, in addition to
extending the dynamic
range of exposure.
You have to look at what it is
you want to say, what it is
that you want to leave.
What is the best thing
of you if not the
images you leave behind?
What is going to outlast you?
It is the imagery that you leave
behind if you choose
photography as the
way in which you
choose to express yourself.
Because there are many other
ways to express yourself.
You've picked this one.
So this is the best of
who you are here.
This is the culmination of
everything you are as a
person, you put in
a photograph.
It's your sensibility.
That's what matters.
So give it the care, and give
it the attention, and create
the image that moves
the viewer the same
way you were moved.
So in this next grouping, we're
going to take a look at
our flowers.
Now, I became known
for my flowers.
And the funny story about them
is I don't really like or
dislike them.
Why I started shooting flowers
was when I was beta testing
cameras, they don't talk back.
And I would get cameras where
the menus would be in
Japanese, and I don't speak
or read Japanese.
So all you have to do is give
a flower a little water, and
we're done.
So it wound up that in the
course of doing these things,
I made some discoveries about
photography and focus.
So let's take a look at these.
And what I want you to keep in
mind when you look at this is
another thing that I invite
you to consider, which is
shoot your portraits as
landscapes and your landscape
like portraits.
That it's the cross pollination
of the two
disciplines that inhabit your
photographs, that yes or no,
are these the portraits
of the flower?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VINCENT VERSACE: One of the
secrets that I have to
photographing flowers is
that they're all alive.
None of them are cut flowers.
I had a friend of mine who
does a lot of flower
photography.
I'd look at his work, and I just
couldn't put my finger on
what it was that bugged
me about it.
Just something bugged me.
It was beautiful, well-composed,
but
there was just a--
you know?
So I was photographing a pink
flower out in front of my
house, and it was moving.
And I figured, well, I have a
clamp, and I have this little
alligator clip thing, and what
I'll do is I'll just pluck it,
and I'll put it in the
alligator clamp.
And so I'm looking at it through
the lens, and I'm
seeing the flower do this.
And I pluck it, and then it went
like that in front of me.
Still a flower.
It still maintained it's shape,
but something left it.
I realized that the thing that
I didn't like about his
flowers was that he was
photographing corpses.
So what I do when I photograph
a flower is that, first off,
they're all alive.
I can't put my finger
on it, but there's
something about it.
The next thing is-- and
let's take a look at--
let's see if I have this
set up right--
this image right here.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine shots.
Does it look like nine shots?
Because what I'm looking at is
what is the journey of the eye
that I want, how do I want you
to go through this picture,
and what's the pretty thing
about this photograph?
It's the blur.
The blur is the pretty thing.
So I want to take
a look at that.
Now, I'm going to show you
two pictures here.
This is in the next
slide show.
That's impossible.
Why is it impossible?
Unless I told you, wouldn't know
that that was impossible,
because this is what actually
should occur.
I'm either going to get this
kid, or I'm going to get that
kid, but I'm not going
to get both kids.
And as wonderful as this
experience was for me, this
isn't a wonderful
picture in that,
yeah, it's a nice snapshot.
Great.
You had a good vacation?
Those are fun kids.
What I want is I want to be
able to tell this story.
I've removed that which would be
disturbing to you based on
the way in which the eye wants
to see the picture, because
you would see both of
these kids in focus.
Now, how do you get there?
This is for you.
Practice.
I practice at--
I knew it was somewhere--
what I practice at is being
able to bam bam, bam bam.
So it's click click click
click, click click click
click, click click click.
He just has to be
99% in focus.
He has to be at 100% in focus.
Even if the emotional moment
is a nanosecond off on him,
that's OK, because it's
still within the arc.
Where do you practice being
able to shoot like that?
While you're there, or driving
your cat, your spouse, your
kids, and all your
friends crazy?
Practice doesn't make perfect.
Perfect practice
makes perfect.
Understand this as well as you
understand yourself, you will
know the outcome of
every photograph.
You need to be like the Borg.
Literally, it's like this.
Resistance is futile.
And the other thing you have to
do is you've got to work in
such a way--
this is for you, and
this is for you--
you have to work in such a way
that you can make it so that
the camera disappears.
I've been taking photographs
since I was seven.
That's when I started
taking pictures.
This is my favorite
story to tell.
I sold my first photograph
when I was nine.
This sounds like, whoa, right?
I sold it to a local
newspaper for $50.
So you're nine years old, $50
is add a couple of zeros.
I took my dad out to lunch.
We went to Woolworth's, which
doesn't exist anymore.
Had two frankfurters each.
He had a cup of coffee.
I had a chocolate shake.
We shared fries.
And like my dad, I left
a dollar tip.
And for the entire 9 to 10
years, I kept saying, dad, you
know, I got that $50.
And there was one point where
he goes, kid, you spent that
$50 years ago.
But I've been taking pictures
since I was nine.
So for me, all of this
is an extension.
And there was a book
about mastery.
And mastery comes
at 10,000 hours.
You beat yourself up sometimes
because you don't know it as
well as the pictures that you
fell in love with, and the
reason why you don't know your
camera as well as the person
who shot the pictures that you
fell in love with is that they
probably had the head
start on you.
Which brings us back to always
carry a camera and drive
everybody around you nuts, and
learn how to shoot flowers,
because they don't talk back.
AUDIENCE: In your presentations,
you were using
a cross dissolve between
all the images.
I'm wondering if it was
intentional in the way you
ordered them and if you feel
like the prior image impacts
the way [INAUDIBLE]
next image?
VINCENT VERSACE: Why can't every
one of my conversations
be like this?
Yes.
That's called landscaping.
What happens is I make conscious
choices about how
they intertwine.
They're not random.
The reason why I use cross
dissolve is because that's the
least visually offensive and
least gimmicky-looking
transition.
Like you get the spinning box,
or the breaking up into this,
or the rippling water effect.
It's like, great.
There are pieces of software
that shall remain nameless in
operating systems that shall
remain nameless that
introduced like when I use my
Cintiq or a pen, and I click
on the screen, I get a ripple.
Or if I move an image,
it goes--
you know, if I wanted to play
a video game, if I wanted
"Star Wars."
It's like in UI design, if I can
put that out there, one of
the things that I love about the
Google splash page is the
philosophy of the Google splash
page, which is don't
muck it up.
It's a great idea.
It like in UI design,
clean, simple.
It's about the image.
It's not about finding my image
underneath the user interface.
So the way in which things get
designed here always appeals
to me as a visual artist,
because it's the
canvas I work on.
You're in support of my work.
You're not the art form, you're
the form that supports
the art form.
And that's a brilliant way of
looking at things, I think,
and I applaud that.
So don't stop doing that.
Please?
But yes, for you, the answer
is I picked that dissolve
because it's the simplest, and
everything moves because it
all tells a story.
Where the first slide show was
set up, how it went from San
Francisco to New York to Paris,
and then that last shot
leads into the flowers that lead
into the portrait, which
is the landscapes
as portraits.
So I'm trying to reinforce
the idea.
Everything matters.
Everything dovetails into
everything else.
The answer to the question
is always, yes.
If you say to yourself,
do you think the
order my pictures matter?
What's the answer?
Yes.
Should I shoot two more shots?
Do you think-- yes.
Uh-- yes.
I had a very wise teacher
named Viola Spolin.
She teaches improv.
She created improv
as we know it.
It's called Spolin technique.
A very wise woman.
Said at the point at which you
say it doesn't matter is the
point at which you say your
career or your character
doesn't matter.
Everything matters.
You just don't know what
significance is until the
large, operatic lady sings.
So I apply that to this.
At the point at which you say
it doesn't matter in your
image is the point at
which you say your
image doesn't matter.
Everything matters.
You just don't know what's
significant until you make the
less pixel sing.
So the job is to consider
everything.
Some things are more important
than others, but consider
everything.
Which leads to I used to
have hair down to here.
Now I have no hair, because
I'm worrying about every
little thing.
So that when I put the
photograph up, what is not
there is any reason to take
you out of the experience,
that the landscaping of the
photograph matters.
Now, I'm going to show
you something, why
infrared is way cool.
This is a picture
of a young girl.
Now, this is shot infrared, and
all three of the pictures
that I'm going to show you
were shot with the same
camera, one modified for
infrared, one not modified for
infrared, using the same lens.
And the shot was done this.
Click, click click.
See this?
Pretty, right?
Exactly.
Not that it's not pretty, but
there's a profound difference
between this and this.
What do you think that is?
Eyes.
What else?
It's the glow.
What you're looking at is near
visible spectrum light, light
you can't see but you can feel
and you're aware of.
I can't explain this, and
forgive me if I sound like an
airy, fairy artist because,
well, I'm about to become an
airy fairy artist.
It's as if there's another
universe I'm photographing
that I can't see, that when I
photograph it feels like I'm
looking at something that
happened 100 years ago.
It's the wildest thing.
It's why I fell in love
with infrared.
You're photographing near
visible spectrum, and you're
photographing some small
degree of heat.
But to truly photograph
infrared, you need to cool
down the sensor.
But that's what causes the glow,
I think, is the heat
aspect of the light.
That's just me guessing, so
I'm not basing that on
anything other than having shot
it for eight years and
looking at it.
I'd like to show you one last
show, and I'd like to show you
this so that you can see what
it's like to shoot things at
street level.
And pay attention to the
buildings, because I want you
to tell me what year
they were shot in.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VINCENT VERSACE: Thank you
so much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]